[Applause]
[Music]
over the past couple years more
americans have become familiar with the
story of the tulsa race massacre where a
white mob burned a vibrant black
community to the ground which is crazy
even crazier dozens of other black towns
have been erased off the american map
not by burning them down but by hiding
them underwater don't know what i mean
well let's find out in a segment called
how did we get here
[Music]
this is lake lanier it's a lake in
forsyth county georgia where people go
swimming and boating and fishing and do
a bunch of other lakey things but before
it was lake lanier it was a town called
oscarville georgia now oscarville was a
thriving predominantly black community
with a church a school and dozens of
homes until the year 1912 when a very
bad thing happened
oh
two very bad things
in 1912 two black teenagers were accused
of rape they were tried convicted and
sentenced to death in a single day and
after they were executed a mob of white
men terrorized drove out or killed all
the black people in the surrounding area
and they did that until the entire black
community of oscarville disappeared
the county went from having over 1 000
black residents in 1912 to zero in 1920.
that story is so sad it makes this story
look like a comedy
after the black community had been run
off the white people of forsyth county
said you know what we could use a big
old lake so they made one right where
the town of oscarville had just been
they flooded the area and literally
covered up the entire town with water
this is what it looks like right now
but the town is still under there the
homes and churches and schools they're
still down there and now people go
boating on top of them
compared to that this is truly a rom-com
now you might be thinking what a weird
isolated incident but just like the rat
who ate the pizza in the subway this
story is both crazy and common
ever heard of collegia alabama it was
once a thriving black community with a
black college the first black railroad
and literally hundreds of family homes
today it's lake martin at least they had
the decency to name it after a black
person
and if you think this kind of thing only
happened in the south let me introduce
you to a place called central park it's
named after that coffee shop on friends
central park used to have a black
community in it called york hill
but the city of new york destroyed york
hills so that they could build the
central park reservoir because if
there's one thing new york needs it's
another place for ducks to hang out but
if you come here don't try and feed
those ducks they are very aggressive
mess around and lose a finger now when
the residents of york hill were kicked
out of their homes they fled to another
black community nearby called seneca
village and then a few years later new
york destroyed seneca village too so
that they could build central park on
top of it
the craziest part of this story is that
i work a few blocks away from a place
where the government disappeared to
black communities and until recently i
didn't know about any of it you know why
because
it worked
they tried to erase black communities
and they came way too close but now
there are people doing the research so
we are finally learning about places
like henry and mckee islands which is
now located under lake guntersville in
alabama and vanport oregon which is now
located under delta park and all of
these towns which are
currently literally underwater
hey wait hold on
what was that last one
old never sink that's a real place
well if we've learned one thing today
it's never assumed something is
unsinkable
there are over 100 drowned american
towns and many were destroyed in the
name of something called development
induced displacement
that's when people have to leave their
homes so the government can develop
things like dams or parks or lakes this
happens to both white and black people
but historically when it happens black
people and other people of color are
undercompensated for their property or
not compensated at all the theory is
that the short-term bad effects are
worth the long-term benefits for the
community but it's not fair if the
long-term gain is mostly for white
people now luckily there's a solution
it's a very complicated system it
involves a series of ah who am i kidding
cut some dang checks that's it
if you're going to kick black people out
of their homes make sure they have the
money to stay on their feet cut a dang
check and yes you can pay their
descendants too because generational
wealth is one of the many things that is
destroyed when you put black communities
underwater so cuda dang check
these drowned towns are part of the
black american history they don't want
to teach you it's ugly and it's gross
and we don't even know all of it and the
more we find out the harder it is to
love this place that would do those
things to so many people and if you're
feeling this way which i often do you
can try loving what this country could
become instead
our history may be full of pain but our
future has limitless possibilities so
look to the future while simultaneously
being suspicious of every lake you see
when you think of the term welfare queen
you might picture someone like this
but i would like to invite you to the
possibility that an actual welfare queen
looks like this
now don't know what i mean let me
explain in a segment called how did we
get here
in the united states a lot of people
don't like welfare they think that
people who receive welfare are
benefiting disproportionately from the
money we all pull together as a society
to help those in need and many americans
have the idea that most of the people
unfairly receiving that help are people
of color but are they let's go back to
1954. it's the year of brown versus the
board of education of topeka and equally
important the year peanut m ms were
invented
now brown versus the board of education
of topeka was not a versus battle
between james brown and a bunch of
kansas school teachers although that
would be great and i would watch the
butt off of it
brown versus board of education was
actually five civil rights cases all put
together one of them involved the south
carolina school district that only
provided school buses for their white
students the black students has had to
cross a river and walk up to 16 miles to
and from school it's like if a triathlon
was swimming running and algebra two and
instead of meadows you gotta get up and
do it again the next day but here's the
important part it's not just that the
education for black kids was unequal
that particular school district was 75
percent black so that means black
parents tax dollars were literally being
used to build better lives for the white
kids now you might call that a unique
distribution of funds but i call it
welfare for white people because the
white kids were disproportionately
benefiting from the money that was
raised to take care of everyone now in
brown versus board of education the
supreme court ruled that segregation in
public schools was illegal but that
didn't stop white parents from getting
their kids more government handouts one
publix once public schools couldn't be
segregated anymore a lot of white
parents started opening private
all-white schools called segregation
academies which is the most on the nose
name i have ever heard you might as well
have called it racist prep i mean
segregation academy go ahead and call it
on the ones and threes elementary
but
the crazy thing about segregation
academies aside from the name is that
almost 200 of those schools still exist
today
segregation academies are one of those
things that should have disappeared
decades ago but somehow didn't like
low-rise jeans or bill maher
or
bill maher
and here's the thing white students are
now the minority in public schools it
makes sense less than half of the u.s
population under 18 is caucasian but
private schools are still very white
like naming your kid braid in white or
pronouncing target target what
like dancing like this white
like
what is that what are you doing are you
feeling a smell what is this
as of 2017 67
of private school students were white
that's two-thirds in a nation as diverse
as ours our private schools somehow have
the same racial makeup as the triplets
on this is us
now i know what you're thinking
shouldn't parents be free to send their
school send their kids to any school
that they can afford yes of course they
should but here's the thing no one
mentions you and i are paying for those
schools
in 23 states your tax dollars are being
used to send kids to private and
religious schools in florida alone
residents pay almost 1 billion dollars a
year to send kids to private schools to
put that in perspective that's slightly
more than florida spends on illegal
fireworks and just a touch less than
their meth budget
so
now we know where to find america's
white kids they're in private school
meanwhile 70 70 percent of our black
children are going to high poverty
public schools
while their parents taxes are being used
to fund majority white private schools
now what rubs many white americans wrong
about welfare is the idea that they pay
a bunch of money in taxes and then
someone else benefits meanwhile black
parents are paying taxes so that their
kids can go to the school from lean on
me while a lot of white kids can go to
the school from dead poets society
i'm just taking other people's word
there there's no way i can sit through
that movie but
let's be clear i'm sure it's great but
let's be clear
the problem isn't just the private
schools no these welfare kings and
queens have also found a way to make
their public schools wider through a
move called succession
secession through a move called
secession succession is something else
it's a great tv show
it's through a move called secession and
if that word has negative connotations
for you that is because you are a human
being with a memory
secession happens when part of a school
district decides to leave the hole in
practice it's when white people
in a district decide they want their own
school system so they create a new one
leaving behind the students of color the
term secession sounds old-timey and
historical but it's something that's
actually happening right now from 2000
to 2017 47 school districts in the u.s
seceded from larger school districts and
every single one of those new districts
is majority white basically the concept
of secession is a lot like the tv show
succession and by that i mean it's a
bunch of greedy white nonsense
so
here's the question if welfare is a
small group of people unfairly draining
money from the taxes that are collected
from everyone then when it comes to
education who's actually receiving
welfare
and who's paying for that welfare
you and i are and if you're not happy
about that go to your local school board
meeting and speak up but when you walk
into that meeting watch out for welfare
queens no not her him
according to a certain kind of person
the kind who would rather have guns in
schools than black history america's
problems boil down to one thing
undocumented immigrants at least that's
what i call them conservatives call them
illegal aliens which is an offensive
term and in 1607 real americans called
them who the hell are all these white
people and why don't they season their
thanksgiving dinner
now when people rant about immigration
they're usually making one of three
complaints first they say there are too
many immigrants next they'll call them
criminals and finally they'll say
they're stealing our elections the only
people more demonized than undocumented
immigrants are people who emerged from
the pandemic totally checked
we had an agreement that involved wine
and soft pants you betrayed me donna
but what if none of these things are
true let's start with the first one
there's too many of them well people are
worried that america will be overrun
with immigrants and we don't have enough
resources to deal with them which sounds
reasonable but what if i told you that
the number of unauthorized immigrants in
the u.s has declined since 2007 is true
undocumented immigrants have been
decreasing for over a decade much like
the number of people doing parkour or
the age of leonardo dicaprio's
girlfriends
now
i know what you're thinking but what
about all that footage of immigrant
caravans coming to the border were they
just a soul train line
first of all i wish and yes
some people are immigrating here from
other countries illegally but people are
also crossing the border in the opposite
direction that is how borders work and
for years more immigrants have been
leaving america than coming in so
technically it's immigrants who solved
our immigration problem it's like if you
found out that the hamburglar was
sneaking into mcdonald's every night and
leaving a bunch of hamburgers
now let's move on to the next concern
that undocumented immigrants are drug
smugglers terrorists or criminals now i
group these three together because
they're all equal parts [ __ ] first
the vast majority of drug traffickers
are us citizens the drug trade much like
a combination taco bell pizza hut kfc is
ridiculously american
and
while there definitely are mexican drug
cartels they're using way more
sophisticated methods than asking people
to freaking jog across the border
recent investigations show that they've
used planes drones and even an
underground rail system with
solar-powered lighting
they have a solar-powered subway meaning
meanwhile in new york city we got this
we'd be lucky to get a mexican drug
cartel in here maybe they can get the f
train to run on time
undocumented immigrants also aren't
terrorists in fact trump's own state
department said there's no credible
information that any member of a
terrorist group has traveled through
mexico to gain access to the united
states zero terrorists that is the
smallest number you can have
even back to the future had a couple of
terrorists and that's just a movie about
not making out with your own mom
so
immigrants aren't drug kingpins or
terrorists but how many of them commit
regular crimes well i've said before
that crime is related to education and
economics not race or ethnicity but
there's one group that totally defies
that research do you know who
juggalos i'm kidding
it's undocumented immigrants because
undocumented immigrants have
considerably lower crime rates than
native born citizens basically it goes
undocumented immigrants american
citizens and then any famous person who
appears in the first 10 minutes of law
and order
like
you know if mark ruffalo is playing the
mailman girl he did it
but it gets better because immigrants
don't just not commit crimes they
actually make neighborhoods safer one
study found a reduction of almost five
violent crimes for every one percent
increase in the foreign-born population
so if you want to improve your
neighborhood don't add three coffee
shops in an overpriced cheese store at
immigrants so that just leaves the final
question are undocumented immigrants
stealing elections the short answer no
the long answer hell no
so why do people think they are well in
2014 in 2014 a group called the
cooperative congressional election study
conducted a survey about voting now at
the bottom was a box that asked people
if they were american citizens the
surveyors knew that inevitably a few
people would check the wrong box and
that's what happened they got a small
number of voters who checked the box
saying they weren't citizens now what's
more likely that a few people checked
the wrong box or that they decided to
use a random survey to confess to a
felony
either way conservatives used that very
small number to declare that this study
meant that millions of people voted
illegally in 2008 and that same
misinformation has been repeated ad
nauseam to say the 2020 election was
stolen as well but just for fun want to
know how many confirmed illegal votes
they actually found in that original
2014 survey
five
yeah much like a guy in a locker room
telling people how many women he's had
sex with the republicans took the number
five and pretended it was millions
so
to summarize numbers of undocumented
immigrants have been decreasing for
years
immigrants aren't criminals and they
aren't stealing elections more
importantly these false accusations say
a lot more about white people's fears of
people that don't look like them than
they do about immigrants but pretending
that those fears constitute a national
crisis well much like a taco bell pizza
hut kfc that couldn't be more american
when many americans hear the word
reparations they think of it as a
monetary compensation for the emotional
impact of slavery kind of like a check
with i'm sorry written in the memo but
that's not what reparations are because
there is no amount of money you could
pay that would make up for enslaving
people
the actual purpose of reparations is to
restore the physical and financial
things that were stolen from black
americans as a result of slavery there
are lots of examples of this but let's
just explore one housing and to do that
let's go back to the year 1865.
that's when bicycles looked like this
and paul rudd looked like this
right before the civil war ended
president lincoln's top general met with
a group of black ministers to ask how
the government could help the formerly
enslaved be successful in america they
said give us some land we can live on
and the general said no problem we have
a bunch we just stole from native
americans
the general issued special field order
number 15 which confiscated confederate
land and gave it back to black people
the government promised every formerly
enslaved black family 40 acres and a
mule which is very practical personally
i would have asked for 40 acres and a
hippopotamus just messed with them
unfortunately what the government didn't
promise was no take backsies because
after lincoln's assassination president
andrew johnson rescinded the order and
left those black families without a
place to live because just like a dental
patient swearing they're going to start
flossing the u.s loves to go back on a
promise now let's skip ahead to the
1930s and 40s that's when cars looked
like this and paul rudd looked like this
at that time black americans were being
terrorized in the south so millions of
them migrated north but many northerners
refused to rent or sell homes to them so
black families did what they've done for
generations they made something out of
nothing they created makeshift
communities and alleyways in cities like
washington dc and then congress came
along and created something called the
alleyway dwelling authority they cited
the eighth article of the constitution
which is if things are going okay for
black people it's time to [ __ ] it up
the alleyway dwelling authority said we
love what you've done with the place but
we want to make it safe for you why
don't you move out and let us fix it up
for you but when they did they put those
houses up for sale at prices so high
black families couldn't afford to move
back so they were left once again
without a place to live now usually when
something that bad happens to black
people it's because somebody said the
word candyman five times
hold on did that count as one of my
times i'll take it back
no the history of kicking black people
out of their homes is it limited to big
cities let's look at a town in maryland
called frostburg in 1866 two black women
purchased land there that no one else
wanted and with it they created
brownsville a community of freed black
people they built a school and a
flourishing community of businesses and
homes owned by black people i think you
know where this is going
the local white people saw what could be
done on that land and they decided they
wanted a school too and you guessed it
they built it right on top of
brownsville they spent the next couple
of decades pushing black residents out
of their homes so that they could build
a college in fact members of the
community were forced to sell their
houses for ten dollars ten dollars for a
house is insane even monopoly houses
cost fifty
the only house that should cost ten
dollars is this one and even then you're
underpaying it's adorable
so what used to be brownsville is now
frostburg state university whose mascot
is i'm guessing the sneaky land thieves
and the university left the residents of
brownsville and their descendants
without a place to live which brings us
back to reparations reparations aren't
just about putting a monetary value on
the harm of enslavement they're about
restoring to black americans the
tangible things that were stolen from
them through jim crow laws housing
discrimination and so many other living
breathing legacies to enslavement and
there is no limit to what these
reparations can look like maybe it's
direct payments maybe it's housing
subsidies maybe it's buying 17 copies of
the book i wrote with my sister lacey
i'm just spitballing here
whatever we do
it's time to do something that bill i
mentioned earlier h.r 40 it was written
in 1989 and has been introduced in every
session of congress since which means
it's 32 years old that's right they've
been trying to pass this bill for an
entire daniel kaluya
let's pass it already so our country can
become something better than it has been
for the past 400 years because if we
don't well then america much like this
guy's face might just stay exactly like
this forever this has been how do we get
here
there are a few things that every
american high school student can count
on experiencing algebra acne and filling
in tiny bubbles
but standardized testing wasn't always a
part of american education in fact just
like your favorite thrift store jacket
standardized testing started out in the
military in 1917 a group of
psychologists created an entrance exam
for the u.s army it was given to new
recruits and the purpose was to separate
those who were mentally superior from
those who were mentally inferior kind of
like what you do when you look at tinder
tender profiles
i know i'm not looking i'm not looking
at dinner
you tell me probably
a few years later a psychologist named
carl brigham seen here right after
becoming haunted
published a study analyzing the results
of those tests he announced that black
people had scored the lowest he claimed
american education was declining and he
blamed that on the intermixing of black
and white people he said the decline of
american intelligence will be more rapid
than the decline of the intelligence of
european national groups owing to the
presence here of the negro what i'm
saying is he sounds like a really fun
guy
now
i guess it is possible that black
recruits actually did worse on that
man's made-up test but here's the thing
when a bunch of white people design a
test around the things they know
then they are by definition designing a
test that white people will do better on
because every test is biased toward the
people who create it if sir mix-a-lot
creates a test about which types of
butts are best you know the answer is
going to be big
so our haunted friend carl here created
a biased test but when he said that his
test proved that black people were
inferior white people were ready to
listen and when immigrants started
showing up in the u.s in greater numbers
in the early 1900s the people in charge
of immigration got a great idea they
decided to use these new intelligence
tests to choose who could enter the us
and who couldn't sort of like a racist
bouncer they were used to prove that
non-white people were at the lower end
of the racial ethnic and cultural
spectrum and they weren't just written
in a biased way they were also written
in english which many immigrants didn't
speak fluently
can you imagine trying to take a test in
english when you don't speak english
that's like me trying to watch a
telenovela i don't understand what's
happening i just understand that the
stakes are
very high
as these intelligence tests became more
widespread white supremacists started
using them for more than just the
military or immigration they started
using them as a scientific sounding way
to justify segregation and even as a way
to justify forced sterilization of
people of color and people who were
intellectually disabled now that is a
very heavy piece of information so let's
just take a moment and reset with a
picture of two animals hugging
there we go
all right you fell for it now
what does all of this have to do with
the sats well at the height of the jim
crow era white schools were looking for
new and exciting ways to keep black
students out and in the 1920s they said
oh you know who we should call haunted
carl
america's college board asked carl to
create something called the scholastic
aptitude test or the s.a.t that they
could use to eliminate undesirable
applicants and carl said stand back i've
been training for this my whole life
harvard was the first school to require
all students to take the sat so i don't
know how to break this to you but
some racist stuff happened at harvard
the test was such a hit other colleges
started using it and by the mid 1900s
standardized testing was widespread
creating an even larger disparity in
access to education these tests became a
barrier to knowledge and generational
wealth for many american families of
color because that was precisely what it
was designed to do for instance sat
designers used old test questions to
design questions for next year's exam
old questions were deemed good questions
if black black and latinx students
scored lower than their white peers so
if white students did well on a question
it would be moved to the new test
centering the test around their
knowledge base basically the old test
was right in the new test like this
see there you go
and i'm not just talking about how they
made the test in olden times on the
october 1998 sat white students scored
higher than black students on every
single one of the 138 questions every
single one they could have saved some
time and just have one question are you
white yes you get a 1600.
now many people have asked how can we
make a test that is more accessible to
students of different racial and ethnic
backgrounds but
as we send our kids back to school this
month maybe the question is why are we
using standardized tests at all because
the goal of these tests was never
education it was always exclusion and
that fact is haunting which i guess
explains carl's face
this has been how did we get here
[Music]
you